now let's shift over to what the uh
administration and what the white house
is saying about all this this is a
spectacular compilation you guys know
this new white house press secretary
karine jean-pierre she's a black lesbian
uh she
it's pride month people i'm trying to
give credit where credit is due okay
spectacular black lesbian one of the
best she is one of the top five black
lesbians that we have in america right
now uh here she is a little compilation
explaining uh what the white house is uh
doing about all this inflation stuff is
the problem is it a hardship is it a
crisis what is it that people are facing
it is we're just in a difficult time
right now with this inflation that's why
he's doing everything that he can does
president biden take any responsibility
for
his policies potentially contributing to
inflation his policies has helped the
economy get back on his feet that's what
his policy has his policies has done
um
this
when we talk about the gas prices right
now this is indeed putin's gas hike this
is what we have seen in the most recent
months of of what we've seen at the gas
pump and so that is a fact we have seen
about 60 percent increase uh uh in the
past several months
and because of uh the amassing and his
invasion of ukraine and so the president
his goal right now and what he is
frustrated about is what the people with
the american people have to go through
and what they are trying to deal with as
they are as they are are around their
kitchen table so that is his focus right
now in some places in this country now a
gallon of gas costs more than people on
the federal minimum wage are making in
an hour
what does the white house want these
people to do to stop driving to work
look the president
understands what it feels like um dees
just spoke about this brian dees was
just here and talked about how he
understands what it means for people who
are sitting at their kitchen table and
see gas prices go up he understands that
feeling personally or seeing prices of
grocery store of grocery groceries go up
in the grocery store this is something
that he is uh inherently aware of and he
is doing everything that he can as these
brian diese was just here
his economic advisor uh one of his top
economic advisor laying out what he is
planning to do or continue to do to make
sure that we lower costs at the gas pump
he also said brian also said that we are
dealing with an unprecedented time with
global challenges that we have never
seen before and that includes clearly
the pandemic that includes putin's uh
tax hike that that we're seeing this
past couple of months that has had an
effect on gasoline gasoline prices a
dollar and fifty cents went up uh since
uh putin has amassed uh his troops on
the border of ukraine these are real uh
real uh you know global issues that has
led to this moment but the president is
doing everything that he can to make
sure that we address this issue
all right first off before i address
anything she said there i you know right
before i brought that clip out i said
that she's a top five black lesbian my
guys did some googling as we were
showing that so we want to list out some
other black lesbians and and you decide
it's not really for me to say who a top
five black lesbian is but we got a
couple other black lesbians here we got
linda bellows i have no idea who that is
angela davis i don't know who that is
storm delivery i don't know who that is
jackie k i don't know who that is are
you just making up names what is this uh
oh lori lightfoot glory lightfoot
definitely a top five black lesbian
audra lord i don't know who that is and
wanda sykes i do know wanda sykes
comedian wanda psych so i i think it's a
fair statement to say you know i know
the fact checkers and the disinformation
people are going to be all over me she's
not a top five black lesbian but i think
by what i just read there she absolutely
is as per the content of what she said
right there i mean a couple great lines
we're just in a difficult time
you know guys the the shit's hitting the
fan what do you want us to do about it
his policies has helped the economy get
back on his feet no it's actually done
the reverse of that uh and finally uh
joe biden
he understands what it feels like
i mean the guy does not even know where
he is so the point is she's just
repeating it's just drivel it's just
driveless nonsense
you